Okay, do you think the jackhammer I amplify or a true rife grody mat would be beneficial to add to my F122 rife?
We've talked about this lots and lots of times, but the jackhammer amplifier is good for people who don't like to cuddle with their bulb.
So if you can't cuddle with your bulb for whatever reason, somebody asked a question later on that we'll talk about that they think the bulb is giving them rigging in the ears and it's causing rigging in the ears, well then put the bulb under the bed with the amplifier.
That will help with that.
So because it does give off a noise and if it's closer to your ears, it could bother you. Some people for whatever reason don't like to snuggle with their bulb, then you can put the bulb under the bed with the amplifier.
Is the grody mat benefit to add? Well, we have the grodyed sheets in our store that you could purchase, just make sure you put the grodyed sheet on the lower half of your bed underneath your fitted sheet.
So it goes between your mattress and your fitted sheet. Underneath your fitted sheet, so it's better the lower half of your bed so it's on just your waist down. That's how you want to use the grodyed sheet.
Well, should you use a grodyed mat with a bulb? No, you should only use the grodyed mat with the foot mat with the Hollywood Pro Wave.
The website says that the jackhammer amplifier will accelerate the output of your true right bulbs, which is right so it increases the amplification, but you don't need it any higher amplification if you're stuggling with the bulb.
It's already going through you. You don't need to go through you and then through the next room. You're just needed to get it in your body. So where the jackhammer shines as if it's away from your body.
Now, you do not get EMF exposure with either of those pseudo-tory about that.